برمجيات او بطاطا الذكاء الاصطناعي عالم
جالس يذهلنا يوم بعد يوم واا جديد اليوم
مجدد نقاش قديم جديد ومرجع الجدل
والحوارات قديمه جديده الخبر الجديد متعلق
بشركه اوبن اي اي الرائده بمجال الذكاء
الاصطناعي وبرمجيتها الشهيره شات جي بي تي
بط الشات هذا مو جديد او من كم سنه حتى
يعني نقدر نقول انه طرح وكانت الناس بتدخل
وبتطرح على اسئله وبيرد
عادي بيرد عليهم على كل شيء بس لكن نقدر
نقول انه النسخه الجديده متطوره اكثر
فالنسخه الجديده غير انها قادره على
الاجابه على الاسئله هي بتميز لما انت
سائل اسئله مو منطقيه او مستحيل احد
يعرفها كمان ممكن ينطلب منها تكتب مقالات
او نصوص وجربها صحفيين واسد الجامعه
وعلقوا على مستوى النصوص اللي كتبتها في
استاذ صحافه اعطى البرمجيه واجب من
الاعطال طلابه والبرمجيه كتبت المقال
والبروفيسور بيقول انه هذا نص ممكن يعطيه
علامه جيد جدا يعني ومن هنا بندخل للموضوع
الجدلي القديم الجديد لكل بنتكلم عنه
النقاشه المتعلق بالذكاء الاصطناعي
يبرمجياته هل هي خطر على العقل البشري هل
بتخلي الانسان اذكى وافضل واللي راح تحول
لنا الكائنات اغبى الاجهزه بتعمل عنا كل
شيء هل الطلاب برحمه مثلا يوقفوا يتعلموا
وتصير البرمجيات هذه تعمل لهم دروسهم هل
راح تصير الاجهزه اصلا اذكى مننا
طيب خلينا ننتقل الى دكتور محمد قاسم
الاستشاري في مؤسسه الكويت للتقدم العلمي
اللي هو راح يجاوبنا على هذه الاسئله اهلا
فيك معانا الدكتور محمد حضرتك يعني جاتك
الفرصه انك تجرب هذا ال ااه يعني خلينا
نقول الشات بط
احكي لنا كيف كانت تجربتك الشخصيه
على معلومات عامه جربتها اسئله واجابات
متتاليه جربتها ايضا على اني اطلب منه
يسوي لي برنامج كمبيوتر
بسهوله مطلقه وبدقه كبيره لا اقول انه في
كل مره نجح في يعني يعطيني اجابه دقيقه
لانك انت شيك على الاجابات
فيعني في بعض الاجابات كانت خاطئه لكن
اوكي على السؤال يعني بالنسبه للطلاب يعني
هل الطالب يقدر يستفيد منه
[موسيقى]
حتى يعني
تلخيص كتاب وهذا الكتاب وهذا الترخيص مكون
من خمس فقرات
500 كلمه كما يطلب المدرس في الدرس ايه
وفعلا عطاني اياها كما هي ف-
فتجبتي قادر على ان يساهم مع الطلاب وهذه
قد تكون مشكله طيب
مع الطلاب وممكن يكون مشكله ولكن يعني في
نفس الوقت احنا متجهين لا محاله لهذا
الاتجاه فايش همم الفوائد اللي نقدر
نستفيده منها مثلا
يعني طبعا في الفتره الحاليه مثلا
البرمجيه اي شخص يحتاج يبرمج شغله بسيطه
جدا وهو مو متخصص للبرمجه يقدر يطلب منه
ويسوي للبرامج وهذه تجربه الكثير من الناس
انه طلبوا اشياء بسيطه لا يحتاج ان هي
بمبرمجه
بلوك مو قادر اكتب قصه معينه ممكن اطلب
منك فكره حول موضوع معين يعطيني البذره
الاولى وبعدها انتقل لكتابه شيء معين
وهكذا يعني حتى يعني واحده من الاشياء
الجميله انه بدل من اني ابحث عن جوجل
حطيتها على تويتر فسوالي كنتمنت على تويتر
من غير ما يعرفون الناس بناء هذا مولي
احنا همم خلينا اقول لك الدكتور محمد يعني
اوردي عندنا مشكله انه ارادي صرنا اكسل
الراديو صرنا بنعتمد على جوجل في البحث
على طول في اي شيء تقريبا الكتب اصبحت
محطوطه على الجنب قصه سرقه الابحاث
والافكار كل ما لها في ازدياد طيب الان
احنا بنجيب جهاز يعني بيعطينا كل هذه
الاشياء يعني حتى انت لما تكون رايتر بلاك
او كاتب عنده مشكله فكره ويجيء يطلب
مساعده من الروبوت يعني هذه نوعا ما برده
يعني سرقه نوعا ما اخذت يعني يعني ايش ايش
صرنا ان احنا في النهايه وان احنا الانسان
المبدع والرضيعنا نازل
فعلا كلام سليم جدا يعني حتى في حدا وهذا
قبل العده سنوات لما صنعوا برنامج اسمه
الحين لا تذكر الاسم لكن البرنامج عباره
عن
منتج لموسيقى مؤلف لموسيقى فلما اسمعوا
الناس الموسيقى شعره انه وين الانسان هل
الانسان يعني لم يعد المبدع وبدل ذلك
الكمبيوتر هو المبدع هذه طبعا اشكاليه
كبيره لان الحين الكمبيوتر وصل لي الزاويه
الاخيره من قدرات البشر وهي القدره
العقليه وبدا يتدخل في هذا المكان اللي
كنا نحن نشعر انه هذا اللي يجعلنا فوق كل
شيء على الكره الارضيه فالان شنو اللي
يسوي في هذا يعني حتى انا سالت همم نفسي
باللغه العربيه
شنو هل الطالب ممكن يستفيد منك وياخذ
المعلومات ويكتب مقالته فقال لي بالتاكيد
يقدر ولكن هذا لا يعني انه راح يتعلم بعمق
همم ياخذ المعلومات بعمق وعليه ان يحذر
ايضا ان قد تكون بعض المعلومات اللي اعطيه
اياها
مستوعب هذا الموضوع بس ما حد ما في اي احد
في مرحله دراسيه ويكون طالب حيستوعب هذا
الموضوع يعني الواحد بده يخلص طيب يعني
انا صراحه عندي مشكله اخلاقيه صراحه دكتور
محمد مع الموضوع
متفق انا تماما انه هناك مشكله اخلاقيه
ليست فقط على مستوى ابداعات البشريه انما
حتى على الوظائف اللي راح تبقى مستقبلا
وحاضرا حتى يعني مثلا كثير من البرامج
الذكاء الاصطناعي اليوم تستطيع ان ترسم
رسمات افضل من الكثير من البشر حول الكره
الارضيه
بمجرد انك اعطينا كلمات يعطيك الرسمه اللي
تبينها وهذا انا استخدمتها تجربتها يعني
شوف يعني اعطيتش مثال قبل فتره كنت اطلب
من برنامج الكمبيوتر عفوا اطلب من الناس
على الانترنت
للروبوتات
[موسيقى]